Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and I am finally back. in. (slam) my.(slam) own. (slam) home.
I haven't even been able to start the new year because I've been touring since the 2nd of January and I just got back
Two days ago because I drove back from Cincinnati, Ohio to Los Angeles, LA
With this dog here!
Say hello to the camera.
Give it a good snuffin.
*singing* Who's a good buppy? It is buppy.
So Chica had a great time in Cincinnati. It was totally worth the trip
I really wish that she could have met Buddi
And it's really sad that she didn't but Chica brought a lot of joy to my family
Especially my stepmom who was really missing Buddy
And now my stepmom is probably gonna be getting another dog but gonna wait until the summer so it's a little warmer out there
It's real cold out in Cincinnati
But I'm back! (Yay!) It took three days of driving to get back! And I was driving alone
And I was just lost in my own thoughts
And it's totally fine cuz I'm an introvert and I need all the time I can get but...
I was lost in my thoughts all by myself...
and I was very alone...
Anyway...
But I'm back. And I'm back for another three weeks until I go back on tour in Europe
Yay, hooray
More
traveling
It's gonna be so worth it though the tour was unbelievably fun
We actually shot a big special for the whole show we had a professional
videographer following us through the whole tour we had someone interviewing us at every stop we
professionally shot the Las Vegas show with like a six camera set up and a director and a whole team behind it and
So we've got a lot of really cool footage to make a cool documentary now. I don't know when that's gonna be done
But when it's done. I'll try to figure out a way to release it that is most advantageous for everything
We're not gonna post it on YouTube probably
but we will try to make it so that it's readily available to as many people as possible without being an
Inconvenience
ALSO
now if you want to go see us on the tour
we are still going to the European shows go-to (www.tour.markiplier.com) come to see them for yourself you want to know where I'll
Tell you with words
starting on February 14th, which is
*awkward pause*
The Valentine's Day Valentine's Day we're going to Tilburg Netherlands Antwerp Belgium Paris France Amsterdam Netherlands
London UK Cardiff Manchester, Glasgow Nottingham, I didn't say any of those right Cologne Germany Berlin, Germany, Oslo, Norway
Copenhagen Denmark, Stockholm, Sweden so if you haven't gotten a ticket yet to see us in Europe
We are coming your way, so thank you so much for that. Also if you go to
markiplier.com without the tour go to markiplier.com you can see I've got brand new merch finally. I've got this one which I
Really really love it's super comfy, but it says I'm a giggly bitch ignore the fact that it's backwards
Hope that I can't even bother to explain. Why but it says. I'm a giggly bitch on there
There's a whole bunch of other stuff available right now on the website if you go to markiplier.com and you haven't seen one of
The cool things that I've got up there go check it out right now. There's also a van t-shirt. There's logo t-shirt
There's a hat. There's a blanket there's tons of stuff so check it out for yourselves
IN
OTHER
NEEEWWSS! *yells at the wall*
Haven't done like a fucking news update and so long and been able to do
*throws sock to face*
In
other news
*sock hits mark on the chest* Ow.
Ow My Boob *laughs hysterically*
In other news!
I
Am Going to be streaming on Twitch more regularly now that does not mean that I am NOT gonna be streaming on youtube that just means
I've actually got it set up ready to go. I did a test stream yesterday, and it was super fun
Just because I actually have things under control
Twitch is a little better set up the communities more established as far as live-streaming goes
And it was just all-around fun to be able to play games that I wouldn't ordinarily
Consider to be "let's play" material, but you know what is "let's play" material anyway? It doesn't mean anything, but what I do really enjoy
About live streaming is it gives us interactivity between you and I and I have it set up in a way
That makes chat very very
Conversable and fun to do so I'm gonna be streaming over there if you want to go over and follow me there
Subscribe
you can go through
Marka-uh or twitch.tv/markiplier, and you can go see that for yourself in other news
I am back in the new year. This is a new year 2018
I haven't even been able to do a freaking review of my best videos from the past year god
Dammit, I meant to do that
But I got so busy with the tour and prepping for Christmas that I didn't get a chance to so here I am
Already almost a month into 2018, and I am not there. I'm sorry. I'm a big piece of shit
*laughs at his misery*
I hate myself so what I need from you guys and
This is kind of important if you guys can help me out and in the comments below
Let me know what your favorite videos of
2017 were we did a lot of really cool stuff this year from a date with markiplier to markiplier tv
We did a lot of cool stuff this year from A Date With Markiplier, Markiplier TV,
Who Killed Markiplier to all the other sketches in between there? We did a lot of cool stuff. We did live streams
We did sketches we did music stuff
We did we did a whole bunch of stuff so I want to know what you guys really really
Enjoyed of last year because going into this next year. I'm gonna be doing different things because last year was very much
my
What can I push how?
Goodly, can I push the stuff that I make this next year like I want it to be the year where I?
explore different things maybe outside of videos with different concepts that I normally wouldn't approach when it comes down to
playing video games or
Writing a book or doing
Music or stuff like that like there's a whole bunch of other things that I want to do, but I do want to reflect upon
2017 as a year as a whole so let me know what your favorite part of
2017 is down in the comments below
I would love to know and I want to create another playlist because I kind of do that every year of the
best videos of the past year or something like that
In other news
I know that everybody in the comments is going to shout at the top of their lungs all the games that they want me to
Play I have a big-ass list of over 42 games
42 games that I've downloaded and I have ready to go for Let's Plays that I'm going to be doing very very
Immediately at the top of the list is your favorites like Subnautica. (Mumbles) I've got
Perception I've got
the- the- *regrets the game that already came out*
Okay, that game okay. All right that game probably already. I recorded that one this morning if it came out at 8:00 a.m.
You know uh?
there's some weird games on the internet
But I've got a whole bunch of them if you have another suggestion that you want me to play a game
I swear, I know I've been hearing you guys. I know exactly what you Shh *touches camera*
It's okay. Shush shush it's alright I got- I got it trust me I got- shh I got it. Hey *messes up camera view*
*kisses camera*
Hey, look. I got it look. It's okay.
(Haters starts to comment)
Got it, please no. No! you still commenting! NO!
NO!! NO!!! NO!!!! anyway, so this year is going to be a lot of fun
I only have about three weeks until I have to go out again for the tour in Europe
But in that time I'm going to be as productive
As I possibly can I've got a lot of stuff that I'm working on my own
I've got a lot of stuff that I want to work on I've gotten a lot of ambition this year
And you're gonna see a lot of cool and different stuff than you're usually seeing for me. I've been getting really good at guitar
I've been getting a lot better at singing
You know I've been doing a lot more like experimental stuff, and I've been doing some writing on my own
it's been a it's been a really good year for me and
And another thing that I want to do is I want to keep doing these um weekly update videos
You know Markiplier Mondays or whatever I used to call them
I-I-I miss doing them because it just is another way that I can connect with you guys and another way that I can actually
Talk with you guys on a regular
Basis and keep you in the loop of what I'm doing because there's a lot of guesswork that happens a lot of the time
But especially when the community gets as big as it is it's almost at 20 million
Which is just unbelievable think about and those tasteful nudes
I gotta I gotta get on
Those I gotta get on those you know step number one is getting in
Shape enough because I've kind of let myself go over the Christmas break. It's very hard to this workout when you're on tour but
Don't you don't you worry let me worry about me don't you worry about me
Let me worry about naked, so I've got a lot of things on my mind
And I've got a lot of things that I want to do you know to start up the new year
I'm just really in a good place. I I was in a good place
I'm not saying that at the end of the last year I was in a bad place
I was actually in a really good place then too, but I've got a lot of hope through this year
and I've got a lot of
I've got a lot of you know resolutions, but they all kind of narrowed down to doing more and talking less, you know
Because I think
Talking about doing stuff is what makes you go crazy because if you can't fulfill what you talk about
That it just makes things in an endless loop, but for what I want to do I
Think it's gonna be pretty cool, and I think this year's gonna be pretty great
So I'm gonna try to do update videos update vlogs every Monday
I can't promise you know I'll be super regular about that
But they also will not always be in this room me talking to you guys right here
I want to go out and about more I've got other things that I want to do
I got the classes that I want to take things that I want to learn in things that I wanna work on
Should be a pretty exciting year least on this side of the screen
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down in the comments below of what your favorite video the last year was in anything other you're gonna
Say to me and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye
BYYYYEEE!!!
Goodbye *slowly wheezes through mouth hole*
AAAaaaaaahhhh